the US government has recently completed
construction of a new internment
facility in Parwan province the
detention facility in part one or d v
where we placed the Bagram theater
interment facility by the end of the
year more than 700 military members from
Joint Task Force 435 will help improve
safety and security for all staff and
detainees the new facility will provide
better living conditions and programs to
help detainees reintegrate into society
after their release the most important
factor is that this facility is a gold
standard in detention operations that is
we provide an incredible level of care
to the detainees equal to what we're
doing in the old facility right now it's
just that we have a better facility with
more space and more capability a much
larger medical treatment area and many
more vocational technical areas that we
can help detainees the new facility also
provides an opportunity for coalition
and Afghan partners to work together to
make Afghanistan more secure this is and
hopefully quickly will become an Afghan
facility certainly gentle McChrystal's
end state as he's defined it is to turn
this facility over to the Afghan
government and let them use their Afghan
correctional officers to run this
facility so our plan is to partner with
the Afghans and work side-by-side you
know so a Guard Force member with an
Afghan correctional officer side-by-side
teaching them how to do detainee
operations
officials say planning is already
underway for transferring the facility
to the government of Afghanistan from
Kabul Afghanistan I'm Air Force sergeant
AJ mo toll